[Music]
and married for money news Oh Mary my
fluffy dog Oh a runaway bride has coned
at least cut oh sorry
conned at least eight men by marrying
them for disappearing after collecting
the dowry money yeah okay sorry I can't
[Laughter]
sit again if you want yeah a runaway
bride has conned at least eight men by
marrying them and disappearing after
collecting the dowry money what is this
[ __ ] India know what how Bobby she
though
they still do dowry yes like [ __ ]
money and cows in the goats and [ __ ]
what is a dowry a same thing you know
like back in a day where it's like so
let's say I have a son or an inn like I
want my son to get married to this girl
so then we give her family like two
goats some shoes maybe yeah and a brick
of gold for the daughter or the daughter
oh but that's old school
yeah I guess they still do it so I can
do this : - that sounds amazing people
still do it I was watching on the TVs he
said where they're doing in Africa
whether you have like a coat and [ __ ]
like that's not a joke like it was like
a goat they were trading it off I'm not
sure if it was something that was so
necessary eyes like value but it's like
tradition or some [ __ ] there's a place
where they literally kidnap women and
make you marry their son my [ __ ]
weird
Hmong people do that [ __ ] terrifies me I
think Kazakhstan yeah Kazakhstan yeah I
saw that
vice right yeah nice so what would you
do if your father try to do that to you
oh my do you run away if my dad might I
would never do that he'll [ __ ] would
make my dad tried to sell me off yeah
for bag of dicks
and for the back some of the violence
against your father or the man that's
trying to become a man was trying to buy
me like what are these nice yeah [ __ ]
would it be looks like Daniel Henney
yeah what if he's handsome oh [ __ ] you
and sell me for a bag of sand if you
want what do you owe your daughter I
have a coin purse filled with sesame
seeds yeah I'll take it it's fine whoa I
have to yeah yeah I don't know you would
have to run away dude [ __ ] that mm-hmm
but he was gonna give your family two
cows eight chickens three goats and a
bale of hay I know somebody who had an
arranged marriage
yes she actually I'm pretty happy though
really
I that's what she told me because I saw
her after high school and she was like
married I said what the [ __ ] would you
marry is that always an arranged
marriage I said what are you cool
something of the Middle East I'm not
sure she was light-skinned in so I don't
wanna say she was Indian but she might
have been like Pakistani or something
but it wasn't arranged marriage and then
she she said she was happy
that's interesting yeah I can't remember
her name but she had a birthmark she was
so this woman this 32 year old from
Thailand
dope yeah so she her name is how long is
it Johnny Yap horn oh that's her name
evgenia poor well my horn is in your
name names we've heard worse names it's
fine she's fine
that's a short name - but that's hella
short that's our nickname so it looks
like yeah this is what she looks like
she Bobby Bob oh my don't shave Conda at
least eight men dance she was actually
dyed woman hustler why sure why does she
match the wall behind her hmm
but yes she looks like the mom that
arranged the marriage for her daughter
yeah yeah but who is she hustling dude
but he's memory so she's gone different
amounts from sad guy and oh man and so
uh so with her the way she's calling
these guys is that they'll go on a first
date and then she'll sleep with the guys
of course and put it out and then
they'll be dating for like a couple
weeks or maybe even some months with
certain dudes and then she'll tell them
that she felt pregnant and that they
should get married and so then that's
when they give her the dowry like one of
them gave her six thousand another one
gave her fifteen thousand and like
they're just giving her all this money
and that's when she'll disappear and
she'll be like oh I lost the baby cuz I
was thinking - I was like I bet you she
[ __ ] sucks a mean dick and I was
right I don't know how people do it dude
like the scummiest people can get sewing
I know this one girl she was a go-go
dancer just like the scummiest cokehead
ever but she's gotten proposed to like
four times in one year one it's because
of what she does with her mouth dude as
for the pregnancy test yeah let me see
the time there's fake ones people sell
fake ones that's Jennifer yeah but but
those guys could have been in love - and
like happy mm-hmm like oh [ __ ] I've
never been with a woman before and I
yeah
is this a how long like what and how
long the time span did this all happen
well they do report that she was able to
marry five different men in just one
week what oh wow we're such weak
creatures all you got to do is kick all
the [ __ ] balls and suck the tip and
that's all it takes is like kryptonite
man fine [ __ ] game must be amazing yeah
what do you think it's like like how do
you how does she do this
she plays the skin yeah I don't know I
think it's because because the girl that
I know she makes them like [ __ ] fall
in love she's like oh I love him he does
this like it makes them feel like
they're the best person in the world and
they'll propose to her and they find out
how [ __ ] insane she is and then she
takes the ring put it this way there's
guys out there that get zero attention
from women and identify if a half-decent
girl comes around mm-hmm they're just
like oh my god I think I found the one
finally God has answered my prayers it's
so sad what has she finds them you find
oh I bet you do you know what it is it's
like you know how y'all get a lot of DMS
from lonely guys that want to [ __ ] ya
and like they'll be like girl I don't
know what it is but I think you're sad
or like they try to say some [ __ ] I
think they're the ones that respond sad
what's up
well they report that every one of her
victims she messaged on Facebook so she
hiding them as a friend on Facebook
she's not even cute she looks like she
makes like a really good like sticky
rice or something you like it Vietnam
where you see the boats and they're like
how old do you think she how old is
looking the bad thing yeah 32 she looks
about 40 something 50 yeah actually 50
that she dent it though man she's
[ __ ] hustling hard guys are just
going to the media and like slowly more
guys are coming out saying I was I won't
say [ __ ] I'd be so embarrassed where you
get ripped off by like a fake like a set
up thing you know like zip in your lips
it's like that same reason why males
don't ever come out about getting raped
by another guy they just they just you
don't you don't say it like it's like a
statistic they're like did you get rid
not I think it's waddle away they get by
women
yeah they don't say anything yeah which
sucks I mean they should well you Pete
you dudes get raped their women oh my
friend my friend got raped by a really
big girl let's hear about that story
[Laughter]
my friend Ernie
he was really so he told me that this
party that left early from he got they
got really drunk and then like really
[ __ ] up and then there was a really
really big girl and everyone liked
hanging out with her because she had the
car and you know she she always drove
everybody around she looked like like
the balloon like really she like yeah
she looked like she man her body was of
a big elementary school lunch lady like
yeah it was natural dude yeah she wasn't
even like like like big with like kind
of like a you're cute you have a cute
face big body nah she was just like
Jabba the Hutt with long hair oh yeah
her name is probably fun but anyways
everyone everyone was like stone and
drunk and whatever he knocked out he
woke up with his pants down
what do you mean he not was he drunk he
went drunk he was drugged he was no he
was drunk and like hi and he just
thought it was fate how much did he
drink dude I don't know but we I left
early from that party so but he woke up
with her riding him he was just like oh
I didn't like he's like oh good he was
in pain no he didn't want it he was like
what the [ __ ] yeah poor guy I know how
he found out he was right though is good
she crushed his pelvis he was in a
wheelchair
we're broken dude daylight yeah well how
was dinner action not even come or
nothing I don't know maybe soft
it could be do it with her no no she was
he was it ashamed or embarrassed like he
was kind of like weirded out when he was
telling us his story like he was kind of
down about it but at the same time he
wasn't that ashamed
so I'm also thinking maybe he just did
it cuz he was desperate
what to pretended to be yeah I guess he
whatever huh yeah woman pregnant what
would you do I would say that she's not
proud she's so fat she can't even tell
difference happens though like when yeah
yeah
the hottest [ __ ] make love yeah it
would be a nightmare nightmare because
in it like in court it doesn't matter if
you were raped like you still are
responsible for that child right oh yeah
yeah but suicide enter your your mind
keeping the baby
oh my problem say yes go celebrate in
Thailand and skydive and you [ __ ]
kick her off the no parachute 100% you
know like in those those like videos
where they're so cool they blindfold
boom and then like they just like push
them off you just blindfold her and [ __ ]
its spar to kick her real hard we don't
we thought I'd be like honey you know
what would be awesome let's let's go get
married in Somalia oh no this is real or
not but I think I don't know in law and
order SVU because this one woman with
like date rape drug rich guys and then
there's like this electric you know
people use this electric sex toys weird
shocks you little there's money you can
shock in your anus and it makes you late
just like that right and they should
take that come and get pregnant and make
a [ __ ] ton of money off them kid and
then they take them of course I'm sure
wherever in and to get the man will want
the baby she's like are your ticket pay
me first though that's like those sports
girls that save the [ __ ] come in the
safley like condom and like try to
[ __ ] do [ __ ] up their vagina or
whatever and get pregnant dude that
works it's dangerous
I don't know it works but I know that
they try to do that what's up you sexy
[ __ ] useless [ __ ] [ __ ] if
you want to follow us you could check
out all our [ __ ] links in the
description box below you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
other than that videos are up there
[Music]